♪ (AMBIENT MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
ANNOUNCER (OVER MICROPHONE):
I wanna thank everyone
for joining us
to celebrate the proudest moment
in Easttown sports history.
And finally,
Miss Lady Hawk herself,
Mare Sheehan!
(CHEERING, WHOOPING)
JAN KELLY: See this yet?
Big write-up in the Tribune.
I'm gonna frame it
and hang it up in your office.
Yeah, please don't.
MOTHER (OVER TV):
My daughter's been missing
for exactly one year,
and the police
aren't doing anything.
FRANK SHEEHAN:
How's your mother doing?
-She's being a hero.
-(CHUCKLES) Yeah.
MARE SHEEHAN: Of all the houses
my ex-husband could move into,
he has to buy the one
right behind mine.
Well, I heard he got
a really good deal on it.
(BOTH LAUGH)
(CELL PHONE VIBRATES)
Hey.
♪ (DRAMATIC MUSIC PLAYS) ♪
MARE:
The Easttown Police Department
received a call
reporting a dead body
in Creedham Creek.
We've decided to bring in
a county detective
-to assist with the case.
-(PEOPLE EXCLAIMING)
How do you like
working with my mom so far?
We're just getting started out.
Any tips?
SIOBHAN SHEEHAN:
Lower your expectations.
-Should we do this outside?
-No.
-All right, let's go, Br--
-Hey, hey, woah.
-Woah, what's happening?
-Mare, what did she do?
She knows what's happening,
Tony, she knows.
All right, let's go.
Are you friends
with these people?
Yeah.
♪ (MUSIC BUILDS) ♪
Why do they call you Lady Hawk?
I made a shot
in a basketball game.
RICHARD RYAN:
Must have been some shot.
Around here, yeah.
PRIEST: The terrible events
of this past year
have ravaged this community.
Hey, Mare. Who did this?
BILLY ROSS:
You get the son of a bitch.
'Cause if you don't,
I'll kill him myself.
MARE: I can feel it...
this expectation from people...
to be something I don't think
I'm good enough to be.
Hey!
I think you're a hero.
You feel I'm a fool.
You're a lot of things
I don't like,
but you're not a fool.
It might be a good thing
to step away.
CHIEF CARTER:
I know what you've been through
and I know you're worth saving.
Recommit yourself.
I'm gonna find out everything.
(TIRES SCREECHING)
Every thing.
♪ (MUSIC CONTINUES,
CONCLUDES) ♪